M.  Perlmutter merci beaucoup pour que
tous les films que
je puisse vous montrer soient super
merci alors que faites-vous ici
lire des livres transcrire de la musique nager à la
rivière sortir la nuit semble amusant,
bien plus tard quand ils ont réussi à arrêter
oh, ça souligne, regarde, c'est
comme ça que nous nous dirons au revoir et le
moment viendra plus tard,
en attendant, nous devrons le supporter
pendant six longues semaines, les muscles sont fermes, pas
un corps droit dans ces statues, ils sont
tous courbés.  parfois incroyablement courbés
et donc pas chalant
donc ils sont d'une ambiguïté sans âge comme s'ils
vous mettaient au défi de les désirer Oh
voir sans mes yeux
y a-t-il quelque chose que vous ne savez pas wow
ça au moment où je suis d'accord, je savais seulement à quel
point je  sais ce qui
compte ce qui compte tu sais
quoi merci je dis ce que je pense que
tu dis
bien je n'aurais rien dû dire ouais fais
juste comme si tu ne l'avais jamais fait
[Musique]
appelle-moi par ton nom et  Je te rappellerai
toi